[Applause]
here are the nominees for achievement in
production design
doom production designed by patrice
vermette set decoration by zuzana
shibosh nightmare alley production
designed by tamara devral set decoration
by shane veal the power of the dog
production designed by grant major set
decoration by amber richards the tragedy
of macbeth production designed by
stephen decken set decoration by nancy
haig
west side story production design by
adam stockhausen set decoration by rena
d'angelo
and the oscar goes to
doom
ever since i can remember i was with my
parents and we were watching the oscars
and and that night that sunday oscar
night was the night that we could
actually
stay out late well maybe christmas was
the other thing but
denis
thank you for allowing us to dream
and thank you for being a great friend
i owe this to you thank you
um
obviously
production design is a
it's a big team so so i've got great
artists also working with me
uh tom brown my supervising our director
obviously right um
dick ferran george hall collie words
and carl probert and the whole team in
budapest it was an extraordinary journey
to do this and i'm super happy that
we're
doing it again so thank you so much
i'm such a cry baby i'm sorry
it means an awful lot and i just want to
thank everyone my team and everyone who
participated and for the opportunity
because of them thank you
[Applause]
and a special
thank you to jean-marc valle my friend
you